انا سعيد الميدانيه قالت قوه ودولتك
الموال الى روسيا ان القوات الاوكرانيه
شنت قصفا مدفعيا على احياء دوله الغربيه
وبين دخول وقفه اطلاق النار حيز التنفي
العسكريه في مقاطعه خرسون بمقتل سته
مدنيين واصابه اخرين جرار روسيا على
المقاطعه الجنوبيه
اسقطت الطائرتين روسيتين واستهدفت بشكل
مباشر منطقتين لتجمع الافراد والعتاد
الروسي دون تحديد المواقع التي تم فيها
هذا الاستعداد
القوه الروسيه
59 هجوما صاروخيا على البنيه التحتيه
المدنيه في عده مقاطعه اخرى
هذا وكشفات هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه عن
اجراء الجيش الروسيه عمليه تعداد في
المناطق التي يسيطر عليها في اقليم دون
باس شرقيه اوكرانيا استعدادا لفرض تجنيد
الاجباريين على السكان في هذه المنطقه
وميدانيا
قام بها الجيش الروسي على محاور افديتك
وبخمه
القوات الروسيه بقصف احياء المدينه بعد
فشل محاولات التقدم اليها من عده محاور
من الدنيا مراسل الجزيره عمر الحاج عمر
كيف تبدو جبهه القتل
من كل حديث عن هذه الهدنه التي من المفترض
ان تدخل عند منتصف اليوم تستمر حتى يوم
الاحد احتفالا او بمناسبه الاحتفال باعياد
الميلاد
التي رفضتها بشكل مطلق واستذكرت ما حدث في
عيد الفصح الماضي حين عامه روسيا عن تهدئه
المشابهها لتخرق هذه التهدئه وهذه الهدنه
منذ السعاده الاولى
لاعلانها على المستوى الميداني وان كانت
العمليات العسكريه ما تزال مستمره ولكن
الظروف كما تشاهدون ظروف الطقس سواء هنا
في مناطق الوسطى وحتى في مناطق الشرقيه
الاكثر بروده تحول دون تقدم الى الجانبين
او تحقيق ما يسعون اليه على الجبهات التي
بات عليها بات فيها الوضع عصيبا مع كل
التحصينات التي اتخذتها مع كل الدفاعات
وكل التعزات العسكريه التي من كلا
الجانبين وان كان كلا اا الجانبين يتواعد
جانب الاخر بحرب وبجوله جديده في الربيع
بعد ان كانت القوات الاوكرانيه همم تحذر
وتقول تستنجد بحلفائها بان القوات الروسيه
تستعد لجوله جديده الان التصريحات
الاوكرانيه على العكس تتخذ طبعا هجوميا
لان الجيش الاوكراني هو الذي يتوعد القوات
الروسيه بجوله جديده خاصه مع كل التعزات
العسكريه التي من شانها ان تغير قواعد
اللعبه خاصه اذا ما تحدثنا عن نظام
باتريوت وكل هذه العربات المدرعه
والمدفعيات بعيده المدى وصواريخ بهذه
المدى التي تركتها اتباعا القوات
الاوكرانيه والتي احدثت همم خرقا في قواعد
الاشتباك خاصه اذا ما تحدثنا عن منظومه
هايمركس وايضا منظومات الدفاع الجوي بارد
التي زودت بها همم زوجتها المانيا
لاوكرانيا في اغسطس وكذلك المدفعيات
الفرنسيه عموما التصعيد كما ذكرت ما يزال
مستمرا العمليات العسكريه مستمره القسم
اتجاه المدن والبادات قبل كان هناك تصريح
لي حاكم مقاطعه الكرامتوس يتحدث فيه عن
عمده مدينه الكرامترسك عن استهداف جديد
للعاصمه المؤقته لمقاطعه دنيا كذلك الامر
كما اورتهم في الخبر هنا قتلى في خرسون
هناك قصف في نيكولاي اضافه الى القصف على
مختلف نقاط في مقاطعه بما فيها لوهانس
وايضا دنيا
عمر الحاج شكرا جزيلا